montagabend in chemnitz
johannes köhler ist gruppenführer bei
der sächsischen bereitschaftspolizei
entwickelt irgendwann so ein gewisses
gespür war eine situation kippen kann
und war nicht wie weit diese richtung
diese richtung gehen gerade die
diskussion die wir heute noch regelmäßig
führen müssen
durch das unverständnis über die
maßnahmen
das ist wirklich mühselig das ist auch
immer wieder das gleiche und das zelt
auch schon allein
knapp sechs stunden zuvor johannes
kohler bereitet sich für den einsatz vor
auch die schusssichere weste gehört
standardmäßig zur ausrüstung sie
anzulegen gehört für den 24 jährigen
genauso dazu wie das der dienstwaffe
natürlich das ist aber trotzdem gehört
zu unserem beruf dazu als polizeibeamten
sind etwas größeren risiko ausgesetzt
gott sei dank war noch nie auch nur
annähernd die situation dass ich an den
gebauter schuss arbeitet denken müssen
schon jetzt weiß der leipziger wie
seinen einsatzbefehl in etwa lauten wird
denn seit monaten müssen er und seine
truppe bei den sogenannten montags
corona spaziergängen die geltenden
maßnahmen durchsetzen
ungewiss ist dabei nur an welchem ort
sie dies tun müssen das erfahren sie oft
erst sehr kurzfristig
wird dort kam es auch in den vergangen
wochen immer wieder zu so genannten
spaziergängen haben ob das heute auch
wieder der fall sein wird wird sich
zeigen
wir bereiten uns aber auf alles möglich
auf alle möglichen
johannes köhler wirkt routiniert die
abläufe sind ihm vertraut begleiten ihn
doch solche einsätze seit er vor 16
monaten nach ausbildung und studium bei
der bereitschaftspolizei angefangen hat
ich komme dass die premiere ein ganz
neues aufgabengebiet dazu aber das
könnte man erfreulich wissen aber
dennoch bin ich hinter wahl meines
berufs laufen vor zufrieden das ist
genau das richtige das total viel spaß
von daher ist alles in ordnung alles
schick ich denke wenn wir dann dort vor
ort sind so ab 17 uhr können wir uns
dann bereit machen dass wir dann auch
die ersten personen gruppen ansprechen
sondern was vergessen
alles klar gut dann formlos
trotz aller erfahrung führt auch immer
ungewissheit mit ungewissheit was der
abend bringt denn in den letzten wochen
gab es bei solchen einsätzen auch immer
wieder angriffe auf die polizei
gott sei dank musste ich noch keine
erfahrungen damit sammeln das freut mich
auch sehr tatsächlich aber es ist
natürlich trotzdem schockierend die
bilder zu sehen gerade medial das haben
wir natürlich trotzdem im blick auf
sozialen netzwerken sei es jetzt twitter
oder auch telegrammen da sieht man
natürlich immer wieder die videos von
angriffen auf kollegen natürlich stimmt
es nachdenklich aber will ernst sowohl
im studium als seine ausbildung dass wir
auf unsere eigensicherung achten müssen
noch ist alles ruhig in chemnitz wir
haben jetzt in der folge die auftrag
erst mal müssen den das umfeld hier im
blick zu behalten schauen ob sich
irgendwo leute sammeln diese sprechen
wir dann an und weisen sie darauf hin
dass hat die aufzüge aktuell nicht
erlaubt sind und in der regel
bereits einige personen denen dann auch
schon nach und unterlassen es dann an
diesen aufzügen teilzunehmen
kurz vor 18 uhr fällt auf dass
ungewöhnlich viele menschen richtung
innenstadt ziehen einfacher
spaziergänger oder demonstranten das zu
unterscheiden oft ein balanceakt für die
beamten
es ist halt immer so wir sind ja die
sogenannten kretschmers milizen der dass
die immer quasi die regelungen der
regierung durchdrücken wollen auf teufel
komm raus die müssen natürlich nicht so
also das ist bußgeld bewehrt ist das
stellt eine ordnungswidrigkeit dar
sondern auch zu teilzunehmen aber wir
haben natürlich immer die
verhältnismäßigkeit im hinterkopf und
werden hier nicht auf teufel komm raus
durchsetzen der gruppierung um die 80
mal
ich bin gestrandet
die lage spitzt sich weiter zu
johannes köhler und seine truppe müssen
zum neumarkt gut 300 menschen haben sich
mittlerweile hier versammelt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die stimmung ist aufgeheizt ganz
plötzlich kommt es zu
handgreiflichkeiten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
andere einheiten begonnen die
anzusprechen und dadurch sich dann auch
vorhin so eskaliert dass eine person hat
damit gar nicht einverstanden war dann
plötzlich geschrien hat wir sind das
volk und dann das ganze gekippt ist weil
dann plötzlich die ganzen leute sich mit
dieser person solidarisiert haben so
dass wir dann auch kurz eingreifen muss
um die kollegen unterstützen mussten
beschimpfungen und beleidigungen gehören
für johannes köhler zum bedauerlichen
alltag montag für montag
[Applaus]
anfangs habe ich da sehr viel darüber
nachgedacht aber das können wir auf
jeder montagsdemo können uns das anhören
da ist schämt euch aber noch eines der
weniger schlimme sachen unter anderem
wollte ich auch schon als volksverhetzer
bezeichnet oder aufgefordert meine waffe
niederzulegen
ist natürlich in dem moment totaler
quatsch
die psychische belastung bei solchen
einsätzen ist groß doch johannes köhler
versucht die wut und anfeindungen gegen
ihn auf der dienststelle zu lassen ich
hab das mittlerweile mir so angeeignet
dass das glaube ich ganz gut hinbekommen
natürlich hier und da versuche ich auch
meine meine freundin mal noch was von
arbeitslosen gerade wenn es jetzt
irgendwas ist so wie heute wo es halt
mal doch etwas dynamischer wurde aber es
ist nicht so dass da jetzt fünf
schlaflose nächte am stück habt das
verarbeitet hat sich gut mittlerweile
der rest des abends verlief
weitestgehend ruth 22 uhr treten
johannes köhler und seine mannschaft die
heimreise nach leipzig an anderthalb
stunden später ist feierabend
wir treffen johannes köhler am nächsten
tag ganz privat lange spaziergänge mit
seiner freundin und hund carlo helfen
ihm wieder aufzutanken
wenn wir beide von arbeit kommen und er
natürlich seine situation hatte wo er
stress hatte und ich auch durch die
ganze situation an schulen natürlich
auch etwas platt bin dass wir einfach
mit carlo ausgehen runde wandern gehen
frische luft schnappen und dann ist das
alles schon gleich etwas entspannter und
genau dann hat man wieder neue energie
trotz schwieriger einsätze wie gestern
bereut johannes köhler seine berufswahl
nicht schon früh wusste er dass er
polizist werden wollte
es war schon immer so dieser das ist
freund und helfer das ist schon das ist
schon cool man kann den leuten helfen
die not sind die unsere hilfe brauchen
und das ist schon schön wenn man halt
auch so eine gewisse position einnehmen
kann
sie wisse wie gerne er seinen job macht
erzählt uns liegen deswegen stehen sie
auch voll hinter ihnen auch wenn sie
sich oft sorgt es ist schon komisch für
mich also wir stehen dann immer trotzdem
in kontakt er ruft mich zwischendurch
mal an männer pause hat oder schreibt
auch meine nachrichten dann weiß ich
dass alles in ordnung ist dann geht das
schon aber es ist grundsätzlich schon
ein mulmiges gefühl immer dabei
die sorge wird wohl auch weiterhin mit
schwingen bei seinen einsätzen im
allgemeinen und denen am montag im
besonderen